two machine gun bullets ripped through
Alexander's legs when he was fighting on
Ukraine's Eastern Front Line
a third bullet was stopped by the mobile
phone in his pocket
his sciatic nerve was severed he cannot
feel his right leg and he is afraid he
will never be able to fulfill his goal
in life in a sport Ukraine is famous for
around the world
[Music]
it is not just a part of my life it is
my life or should I say it was but now I
need to find something else
here's Alexander competing in 2016.
he rose to become kharkiv Regional
champion
before returning to fight in the war
last year he lived in France where he
became Regional champion in nice
[Music]
person because I grew up without a
father how can a mother raise a man
alone I got into boxing and it radically
changed me as a person it hardened my
character and no matter the challenges
like being in the army or on the
battlefield or here in hospital I'm
holding on I can take a punch
there is no surgeon available in Ukraine
who can perform the necessary operation
that Alexander needs in order to
walk unaided and potentially box again
he aspired to be a national champion and
one of the reasons is because boxing in
this country is often described as a
national obsession
this is former multiple world
heavyweight title holder and now mayor
of cube Vitale Klitschko visiting the
front line town of Bahamut wearing the
color dollars of Freedom this is current
WBO WBA and ibf heavyweight champion
Alexander usick
[Music]
there are boxing gyms like this one
established 40 years ago right across
Ukraine
[Music]
men who used to train here are now
fighting on the front lines
some of these boxes may eventually do
the same
has been training here since he was 12.
he joined a territorial defense unit
when Russia invaded last year
the war makes it more difficult to train
but when there's electricity and water
available training feels like a
celebration
we are lucky at this gym compared to
places like maripole which fell to the
Russians and bakmut where fighting is
heavy
we can come here thanks to the men
fighting on the front lines there are
guys who trained at this gym and are now
fighting and some have been injured they
were warriors in the ring and they are
warriors in life
for now Alexander continues his grueling
daily exercise
you can only hope he gets the operation
he needs so he can fight again
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera Kiev